[Music]
let's go to
uh let's try caitlyn in fresno
california what's up caitlin
hey doctor john i need help kind of
processing through the recent school
shooting in texas ah yeah
yeah i kind of do too can we do that
together
yeah absolutely so i want to give you a
little background before we go into it
because it'll help you understand where
i'm coming from
i'm a current teacher in an elementary
school and before i was a teacher i was
in emergency services for about nine
years and i'm currently trying to leave
and go back into
emergency services more on the law
enforcement side so i have a lot
rattling around in my brain regarding
both sides of that shooting
so you told me about the professional
stuff
you've been a teacher in a classroom
and you've played that scenario out
in your head right
yes every almost every week yes
um
you've also been ems
and you've shown up not to have seen
that bad but you've shown up to some
stuff right
right so when they say
bodies or
children or you have a different
visceral feeling than most because most
of us
that's in my gut yeah that's right
because you've shown up on a scene when
a child hasn't made it right yes yes and
you've watched people
that it's a sp it's a different kind of
cry
nothing comes out it's almost like a
throw up cry at the same time you've
seen parents do that right
yeah yes
so what makes you so i tell you that to
tell you i want you to honor your body
in this because you've seen this stuff
this is a part of you this is different
this is not an academic exercise or just
some stuff you saw or learned
this is for real is that fair
yes okay
why do you want to be a cop
i feel like i really miss parts of the
tangible
elements that i had at ems and i know
in the school system we are helping all
these kids but i miss the tangibility
and the problem-solving components of
that world and okay of my skill set so
one i don't know how who
i don't know how you came into the world
but i wish more people had a spirit of
cert you're like you just are put on
earth to serve right
i believe so yeah so great man so great
you're amazing
um all right so what do you this is
gonna sound awful but
i process what happened in uvalde
differently with different groups
with my
law enforcement friends
it's guttural
because they see what appears to be
catastrophic screw-ups
right
you see that too
yes so these are my buddies who are in
badge and they go what are you doing
and
they feel the heat of everybody in the
world blaming police for everything and
here they are getting back in the car
and going back on patrol again today
right yeah and they also know that you
can train all day seven days to sunday
when you're in a building
where bullets are flying
and there are children
that everything is different than you
think it's gonna be i've been in a
building
full of uh students during an active
shooter i've been there it's different
than we trained it's the same but it's
different in your body you know what i'm
saying you've been there
so i also am a parent of a six-year-old
and so i grieve that with parents
differently
i'm also a texan
who
has guns
and i
like what what is ha and i also
have common sense and i'm not a [ __ ]
right so it's it's a it's one of those
across the board spec like i'm grieving
this in 50 different ways and i'm trying
to solve it tomorrow for my community in
50 different ways right so i tell you
all those things to say you have
permission on this show
to grieve it across the board
but i want you to speak into it like
how can i help you with what you which
particular thing you're struggling with
i think because of both sides of that
i kind of feel like i know too much
and in the sense of like
a lot of teachers can kind of go around
and say they don't know what they don't
know in regards to safe
and tactical kind of things and i almost
know just enough to know too much to
know that we are
i mean for lack of better terms kind of
sitting ducks in these classrooms in a
lot of ways and so i'm having a hard
time kind of processing that in in
almost a point where i'm finding myself
having a hard time respecting my
colleagues and and that lack of that
chain of command and i don't know if
they would know what to do like
let me let me tell you no
exactly that's not their job but no
right
um so
two things you can do with that
number one is
you can feel that okay your feelings are
right like you you are trained as an ems
person or as a law enforcement person to
walk into a room or a situation and say
this is not safe this is not safe this
scene is not secure right let's say
you're trained to walk into a room and
scan the room
you're trained as a teacher
that when people lack insight or
knowledge into a certain thing that your
job as a teacher is to help
bridge that gap
yeah and so
feeling that and understanding is
this is why things like 911 this is why
things like covid this is why things
like these shootings are so unmooring is
that we live with a certain level of
oh that's all going to be all right
and when you spend time with military
folks you spend time with first
responders they go yeah but it might not
be because they've seen it right
and that was the joke with my old man he
was a homicide detective it was always
a hundred percent of his day was dealing
with things that never happened
nobody gets hacked up with a hatchet but
on tuesday they did and that's where he
spent most of his day right and nobody
ever gets in a 17 car pile up it
except on wednesday and that's where he
spent all of his day right so as a
police officer you're trained to walk
into situations that no one ever sees
and you're trained to walk in and
try to make sense of it and as a teacher
you
you teach people and so a way you can
make here's the words how am i going to
make meaning of these feelings okay okay
i'm gonna offer a class
i'm gonna any teacher who wants in on it
i'm gonna teach you um here's the right
way to do that hey principal i'm i'm
willing to i've got a background in this
i'm willing to
teach the
the folks hear about this i'm willing to
hold a small group i'll get coffee and
donuts um and have all the teachers who
want to show up and just to debrief like
a cis like a critical incident stress
management like a debrief how are all
y'alls teachers everybody okay this was
what happened to scary and we all
realized we're pretty freaking
vulnerable in here you see i'm saying
like how am i gonna make what am i gonna
do how am i gonna make meaning of this
and then be very
be very graceful with the teachers the
people who cannot wrap their head around
it
right it's one of the arguments that i
hear like we just need to arm all the
teachers
no
hey you work with teachers no you don't
right no but b
there you go right and so that's a
political thing right but the idea is um
what some people cannot put their head
there they can't go there i'm going to
be graceful with them right that's not
i'm not going to beat them up for them
you don't know what's coming it's that's
not helpful that's just going to shut
them down further right
um ultimately the question is do you
want to stay a teacher or you want to go
to law enforcement and what role of
service you want to be a part of and
here's what i'll tell you
there are and you know this idiot
teachers i've worked with them i was one
actually
um there are teachers who aren't great
no teachers who are incredible
there are going to be police officers
who are remarkable and they spend every
minute of their life wanting to help and
love and serve their communities and
there's gonna be idiots
who screw it up
and the goal is to please get those
folks out and to continue to support and
honor and love those who are really
trying to do the best they can with what
they got does that make sense so yeah
all i had to say is
because you're a servant there's not
going to be an arena you go into where
it's going to be perfect and that it's
going to be free from tons of outside
armchair quarterbacks
and it's for you you got to always
remember why you're doing this in the
first place
yeah i kind of ground myself in that so
that it goes
yeah greg hey
nothing else just remember
um
i know enough to know that in the middle
of the night if something goes down i'm
gonna call 9-1-1
yeah you know what i mean and you you
will be the person who shows up for me
and my little kids and my wife
and my dogs and my chickens except you
can let the chickens go they're fine
they drive me crazy right here i'm
saying like remember me yeah remember my
family remember my little kids when the
news is crazy or when you see some
police officer do some stupid racist
idiot thing that's not everybody it's
not most everybody
and let's remember the family on the
other end of that phone does that make
sense
it does yeah
um
i don't know if that's helpful or not i
feel like i just been talking a lot i
feel like like hey let's process this
together and i'm going to talk for 10
minutes without you without breathing
right um
okay i just threw a lot at you how are
you
i'm good i think um
i i also i like the idea of the class
and i think i need to kind of figure out
a way to also bridge it
up to like the district office level two
in terms of like
physical things that we can do around
the school
um so a great thing you can do is to
pilot it pilots the word like a pilot
practice it give it a shot
and if it goes well with five or six
teachers in your little grade unit then
maybe the principal lets you do it at
your campus and if that goes well then
you and your principal approach
the region or the school district and
you see what i'm saying so don't go
don't be like i've got a program
man they're getting
bombarded of things
but start start with the human part hey
i know five teachers around me they're
kind of freaked out
we're gonna get we're gonna get coffee
in the evening we're gonna go to sonic
get some drink and we're just gonna sit
in a circle and say how are you and how
are you and how are you because a lot of
teachers are replaying this stuff in
their head and they're terrified because
they've got nobody to talk to about it
yeah and you can
think one way
and yeah i think i just see it
differently and
but i also have that humanity and
compassion side of the teacher and so
that's right that's right
okay the world is better because you're
in it caitlyn i'm really grateful for
you
thank you guys for john so two things
remember your feelings are real and you
get to have them
and then the question we always want to
get to is how am i going to make meaning
of this what do i do next
right
and man as being able to be a teacher
and law enforcement and
such important shout outs to our law
enforcement folks such important shout
outs to our teachers
and such
all everybody grieving from all over
this mess and to my brothers and sisters
who are police officers with kids who go
to school
um the ones i've talked to this has been
mess man weeping and sadness and i can't
believe that they just sat in the
hallway for all those things and the
tactical questions and the kid questions
and the
follow-up questions all of it man
as a country we got to grieve and we got
a bunch of follow-up just a mess man
what a mess
be like caitlyn find places in your
community where you can surf now where
you can throw fits and throw water
balloons and throw rocks and throw
bricks and scream where you can actually
sit down with people and serve